Hello and welcome to a very, very special bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收听《老爸老妈的浪漫史幕后故事》一期非常非常特殊的特别加更节目。
Once we like to call general questions.
我们喜欢把它叫做“通用问题”。
General questions.
通用问题。
Now I feel like everyone's pausing a little too much.
现在我觉得每个人都停顿得有点太久了。
Is there a lag?
是有延迟吗？
General questions?
通用问题？
No. No, Alec.
不，不，亚历克。
It's technology.
这是技术问题。
You invented this damn game and you can barely play it.
这该死的游戏是你发明的，结果你几乎都不会玩。
Anyway, I'm I'm Josh Radder.
不管怎样，我是——我是乔希·拉德纳。
I am here with my co-host Greg Thomas.
我和我的联合主持人格雷格·托马斯在这里。
We are talking about how, hello, Greg.
我们在谈论，呃，你好，格雷格。
We're talking about how I met your mother episode, what is this, 10, the limo?
我们在谈论《老爸老妈的浪漫史》哪一集，这是第几集，10集，加长轿车？
Episode 11.
第11集。
It's 11.
是11集。
It's 11, because yeah, it's the exact midpoint, right?
是11集，因为，是的，这就是正中间，对吧？
20, 11 out of 22, boom, midpoint, pivoting into what's coming up.
20集，22集里的第11集，轰，正中间，顺势承上启下。
Episode 11, the limo, which we covered pretty in depth in the last regular episode.
第11集，《加长轿车》，我们在上一期常规节目中已经深入讨论过了。
But we here, eer, here, we are...
但是我们在这里，呃，在这里，我们在……
We are, we are, are we, we are...
我们在，我们在，是我们在，我们在……
Clean your questions...
清理你们的问题……
We are leaving your questions about the limo, and we can go a little deeper into the themes here, but Alec what do you got for us?
我们在解答你们关于加长轿车的问题，我们可以更深入地探讨一下其中的主题，不过亚历克，你给我们准备了什么？
What did the people want to know about?
大家想了解什么？
Sure the first one, a question that we did answer in the regular episode, but then she said something very cool that I want to point out, Charlotte 33333 she wants to know about how you shot in the limo, we did cover that.
当然第一个问题，我们在常规节目中其实已经回答过了，但她随后说了一件非常酷的事，我想指出来，Charlotte 33333 她想知道你们是怎么在加长轿车里拍摄的，我们确实聊过这个。
I just want to mention that she says, I studied this episode in class and I watched it and read the script about 20 times.
我只想提一下她说的话：我在课堂上研究过这一集，我看了大约20遍，还读了剧本。
I said to her, what class?
我问她，什么课？
And she said English class talking about gender dynamics in 2000s sitcoms.
她说的是英语课，讨论2000年代情景喜剧中的性别动态。
Discuss.
请讨论。
Oh, my God.
哦，天哪。
Well, first of all, if there if she wrote a paper or did anything like any material about that, please Charlotte, send it to us because that would be amazing to see.
首先，如果她写过论文或者做过任何相关的材料，求你了，夏洛特，发给我们看看，因为那一定太棒了。
I'm wondering why that episode, why does that episode exemplify something about that topic in her mind?
我在想为什么那一集，为什么在她心目中那一集能成为那个主题的典范？
Alec, I'm just going to ask you all these questions and as if you have the answer to them.
亚历克，我打算把这些问题全都抛给你，就好像你知道答案一样。
And then you'll talk about them on your general questions later than you do separately from this one.
然后你稍后再在你的通用问题里单独讨论它们，跟这一期分开。
Yeah, I mean, I imagine if something is of its moment culturally, even if it at the time doesn't look like it would be an obvious candidate for a course of study in college.
对，我是说，我想如果某种东西具有强烈的时代文化特征，即使它在当时看起来并不像是大学里适合拿来当做研究课题的显眼候选。
If you're so sociologically inclined, historically inclined, like it does make sense to pay attention to, because contained within that is a lot of moors and customs.
如果你具备社会学和历史学的眼光，这确实是值得关注的，因为其中包含着大量的风俗和习惯。
I mean, it's like Jane Austen or something, like you want to know about that time, look back on what was popular at the time.
我的意思是，这就像简·奥斯汀的小说一样，如果你想了解那个时代，回头看看当时流行什么就行了。
So, but I am curious, I'm straining to remember.
所以，但我很好奇，我努力在回想。
One thing that happens to me is I, My brain gets hooked on the episode we're currently on, and it's hard for me to get back into the space of limo, just as it was hard to get back into the actual limo after a break.
我身上发生的一种情况是，我的大脑会被我们当前正在聊的那一集给套牢，很难再回到加长轿车那个空间里，就像休息过后很难再回到真正的加长轿车里一样。
But yeah, what do you guys think regarding gender dynamics with an episode?
不过，是的，你们觉得这一集的性别动态怎么样？
I wonder if it was just chosen at random, like if it was just like, well, let's take a how much mother episode and just choose it, it's just gonna exemplify that year and that time, it was just to throw in a dart at the board, it could have been any episode, or if it's this one, I mean, the whole show, we talk about this all the time on this podcast of, there is a gender flip on the show, right?
我在想这会不会只是随机选的，就像随便挑一集《老爸老妈的浪漫史》来研究，它刚好能体现那个年份和时代，就像往靶盘上随便扔飞镖一样，换成任何一集都行，还是说特指这一门心思就是它？我是说，整部剧里，我们在播客里经常讨论这个，剧中的性别设定其实是反转的，对吧？
These are men being like sensitive and wanting, you know, Ted and Marshall wanting this sort of like domesticity and wanting to have a family and wanting to get married.
这些男人表现得很敏感，并且有所渴望，你知道，泰德和马歇尔渴望这种家庭生活，渴望组建家庭，渴望结婚。
And like Barney is obviously the outlier and Murray against all that.
而巴尼显然是个特例，反其道而行之。
And then these two women are often sort of like embodying more masculine traits at times, especially Robin, but Lily too, really.
然后这两个女人有时往往体现出更多男性的特质，尤其是罗宾，但莉莉其实也一样。
And so we did play with that.
所以我们确实玩味了这一点。
It wasn't your average to come sort of reinforcing old tropes at the time, I feel like it was kind of fresher tropes are creating their own little world and milieu of it all.
我觉得它并不像当时那种只会强化陈词滥调的普通情景喜剧，它更像是一种比较清新的设定，创造了他们自己的一个小世界和环境。
Again, I wonder if that's what Charlotte was talking about.
再次声明，我在想夏洛特说的会不会就是这个。
I hope so.
希望如此。
I hope it wasn't like, this show is terrible and it's pretty cool to check.
我希望它不是那种“这个节目太糟糕了，去看看还挺酷的”的感觉。
I don't know if she tore out a new one or if she was like, but we definitely liked exploring and sort of subverting some of those older gender tropes on the show for sure.
我不知道她是痛骂了一顿还是怎么的，但我们确实很喜欢在节目中探讨并颠覆一些旧有的性别刻板印象。
Well, certainly that's all at play.
嗯，当然，这些都在发挥作用。
And we've all talked about that a little bit, but I also think there's something interesting about how women are portrayed on the show more generally.
我们都对此讨论过一点，但我也觉得，关于女性在剧中的整体形象塑造，有一些很有意思的地方。
Robin and Lily and certain other female characters are given a very rich interior life and dimensionality.
罗宾、莉莉以及某些其他女性角色被赋予了非常丰富的内心世界和立体感。
And then there are other women who float through as kind of like Ditzy Barney toy things.
然后还有其他一些女性，就像无脑的巴尼玩物一样在剧中飘过。
just that kind of like are that week's kind of sacrificial thing at the Barney Altar or something.
也就是那种成为该周献给巴尼圣坛的牺牲品之类的东西。
Yeah.
是啊。
You know, I think like part of that is set up to show Barney's evolution that he looks at women.
你知道的，我觉得部分原因是为了展现巴尼看待女性的演变过程。
He quite literally objectifies them.
他简直是在物化她们。
They are objects.
她们是物品。
They are playthings.
她们是玩物。
are, it's about with not depth, you know, like it's about, I mean, a kind of crude term is body count, you know, how many women can he be with, even in one night, you know, how many numbers can he get, how many connections can he forge, how many women can he take home or get to their place.
而且，这关乎的不是深度，你知道的，就像是，粗俗点说就是“战绩”，你知道的，他能和多少女性在一起，甚至在一个晚上，你知道的，他能拿到多少个电话号码，他能建立多少联系，他能把多少女性带回家或者去她们的住处。
But, but, you know, that does set him up for later to be kind of rocked and surprised and not entirely pleasantly to find himself falling for various women.
但是，你知道的，这确实为他后来受到震撼、感到惊讶——而且并非完全愉快地发现自己爱上了不同的女性——做好了铺垫。
Yeah, and one thing I like better.
是的，我更喜欢的一点是。
The thing I like best with Barney about these early episodes or any episodes of the show is watching him just how much he fails.
在早期剧集或该剧的任何剧集中，我最喜欢巴尼的一点就是看他遭遇了多少失败。
His ruses work such a slim percentage of the time, and he's clearly making a lot of these numbers up.
他的诡计成功的几率微乎其微，而且很显然，他的很多战绩都是编造出来的。
And in fact, when you see him succeed, and he does sort of lie his way into hooking up with the woman, It's far less enjoyable to watch because you're like, no, you shouldn't be succeeding at this.
事实上，当你看到他成功时，而且他确实通过撒谎和女性好上了，观看体验反而没那么好了，因为你会想：不，你不应该成功。
And in that sense, that's sort of like when we have those women on the show, I'm like, we didn't do much, we didn't do them a favor here.
从这个意义上说，这就有点像我们在节目中安排那些女性角色时，我会觉得：我们在这里并没有帮她们什么忙。
You know, like a woman actually being seduced by Barney, like, it's not a great role to play.
你知道的，就像一个女性真的被巴尼诱惑了一样，这并不是一个很好的角色。
She's sort of in a helpless position at that point.
那种情况下，她有点处于无助的地位。
And it's much, I sort of cringed some of that now.
现在看其中一些情节，我有点感到尴尬。
I think the far better thing with Barney is to watch things not work out for him.
我觉得关于巴尼更好的处理方式是看事情对他来说并不顺利。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Well, it's kind of the tricky.
嗯，这其实挺棘手的。
We've talked about this, but we talked about Oliver Stone and Gordon Gecko, right?
我们讨论过这个，我们聊过奥利弗·斯通和戈登·盖柯，对吧？
Oliver Stone is an incredibly left-wing filmmaker who was trying to create a villain, and that villain became a hero to a certain kind of stockbroker dude, posters on the dorm, and all kinds of stuff.
奥利弗·斯通是一位极其左翼的电影制作人，他本想塑造一个反派，而这个反派却成了某种股票经纪人老兄心中的英雄，宿舍的海报上到处都是他的形象。
Greed is good, getting flipped around as if that's a virtue instead of of a condemnation.
“贪婪是美德”，这句话被扭曲了，仿佛它是一种美德而不是一种谴责。
And I think whenever you're trying to portray, you know, let's say like racism or something, you know, it's quite ugly to watch.
我想每当你试图描绘，比如说种族主义之类的事情时，看着其实挺丑陋的。
And you're depending on the good faith interpretation of the audience to see that as something odious.
而且你需要依赖观众的善意理解，才能看出那是令人厌恶的东西。
But in the wrong hands, it can be repurposed.
但在错误的人手里，它可能会被重新利用。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yes.
是的。
So when when context really matters here, yeah, like when people want me to start, it gets removed from kind.
所以当语境在这里真的很重要时，对吧，当人们希望我开始时，它就脱离了某种类型。
Yeah, people want me to sign the bro code.
是的，人们想让我签署兄弟会准则。
And I sometimes want to say like, how are you reading this book?
我有时想说，你到底是怎么读这本书的？
Like what?
怎么会这样？
Yeah, it's supposed to be a parody.
是的，这本该是一个讽刺。
Yeah, like, yeah.
是的，就像，是的。
And sometimes people adopt it as their life philosophy.
有时人们会把它当作自己的人生哲学。
And that's always been, I think your and Carter's difficulty in talking about Barney are getting, you know, kind of rattled when people say like, Oh, you couldn't get away with that.
我认为这一直是你在和卡特讨论巴尼时的难处，或者当人们说“哦，你现在根本不可能拍出这种剧”时，你们会感到有点困惑。
You know, today, and you're like, we weren't trying to get away with it back then we were we were holding it up for a kind of mockery or a kind of, you know, we never wanted people to be on the side of him, but that's also a testament to Neil's seductive powers.
你知道的，当年我们并不是想打擦边球逃避审查，我们是在嘲讽它，或者说，我们从没想过让人们站在他那边，但这也是对尼尔个人魅力的证明。
You know, he played him as such a seductive charming guy that people so charming, so likable.
你知道的，他把这个角色演得非常有魅力、迷人，人们觉得他太迷人了，太讨人喜欢了。
Yeah, he humanized the role and the journey with Barney over nine seasons was to humanize him and see the kind of the broken parts of him that led him to be that way and to show some amount of evolution.
是的，他让人性化了这个角色，巴尼在九季中的心路历程就是让人性化他，看到他破碎的部分导致他成为那样的人，并展现出一定程度的成长。
But of course, people like picking out the fun parts, right, picking out the sort of literal like, ah, the Broco, let's talk about the Broco and it's great.
但当然，人们喜欢挑出有趣的部分，对吧，挑出那种字面意思上的，啊，兄弟会准则，让我们谈谈兄弟会准则，这很棒。
It's fine if people want to watch it that way.
如果人们想那样看，也没关系。
But I suspect it kind of, it feels to Carter and I as creators of the show, probably kind of like when Bruce Springsteen hears people thinking, uh, born in the USA is a patriotic song.
但我猜，作为节目的创作者，这给卡特和我一种感觉，大概就像布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀听到人们以为《生于美国》是一首爱国歌曲时的感觉一样。
And do you realize that people have not listened to one word of anything but the chorus born in the USA?
你难道没意识到，人们除了“生于美国”这句副歌之外，连一个字都没听进去吗？
Like they just heard those few words and the rest of the words just go by completely unnoticed and the radar.
就像他们只听到了那几个词，其余的词雷达完全没捕捉到，直接飘过去了。
And if you read them or if you study those words, they are very much not a pit.
如果你读一下或者研究一下那些歌词，它们绝对不是什么无底洞。
They are a searing critique of America and war and economic realities and how we treat our veterans.
它们是对美国、战争、经济现实以及我们如何对待退伍军人的严厉批判。
It's an amazing song that's completely misunderstood.
这是一首被完全误解了的精彩歌曲。
And Bruce Springsteen must be out of his mind for 40 years.
布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷这40年来肯定疯了。
This is not what this is.
这根本不是那么回事。
And sometimes it's that way with Barney.
有时候看巴尼也是这样。
And somehow we got here from gender stuff, but I guess it still relates, right?
不知怎么的，我们从性别话题聊到了这里，但我想这还是有关系的，对吧？
We're still on topic, but yeah, yeah Yeah, no, I think it's a big I think it's a big thing to discuss and You know he he was yeah, he was emblematic of it.
我们还在主题上，但是，是的，不，我觉得这是一个很大的，我觉得这是一个很大的讨论话题，你知道，他确实，他就是这种现象的象征。
I also think there's something I think there's something fun about watching people behave terribly it like yeah, I remember um West Craven said something about like we a horror movies don't provoke bad behavior, they actually replace it.
我还觉得，看别人表现得很糟糕其实挺有意思的，就像，我记得韦斯·克雷文说过，恐怖电影不会引发不良行为，它们实际上取代了不良行为。
Like it allows us to experience our shadow in a collective way that's actually quite healthy, right?
就像它允许我们以一种集体的、实际上相当健康的方式体验我们的阴暗面，对吧？
And I think, you know, sometimes we can watch, I mean, it's just fun to watch characters misbehave because we know we would never do that, you know?
我觉得，你知道，有时候我们可以看——我是说，看角色行为不端挺有意思的，因为我们知道自己绝不会那样做，你知道吗？
I think like, what's his face?
我觉得，比如，那谁来着？
Ricky Gervais has talked about like how uncomfortable he is personally making people feel uncomfortable.
里奇·热维斯曾谈到过，他自己让别人感到尴尬时，他内心有多不舒服。
And creating the office allowed him to play a character that just walks right into the propeller blades all the time.
而创作《办公室》让他能够扮演一个随时都会一头撞上螺旋桨的角色。
But it was something that he couldn't bear doing in his real life.
但这却是他在现实生活中无法忍受去做的事。
So he got to do it in a fictional way and kind of work it out that way.
所以他得以在虚构中完成这一切，并以这种方式去克服它。
And I think that's part of the joy of Barney is he seems to be unshackled by certain societal more is that I at least have agreed to, and you guys have agreed to them.
我想这也是巴尼身上的一部分乐趣所在，他似乎没有受到某些社会道德规范的束缚，至少我和你们都已经接受了这些规范。
And not to say that I would want to behave like Barney if I was given the choice, I actually wouldn't.
这并不是说如果给我选择的话我想表现得像巴尼那样，我其实不会。
But there's something, you know, I had a wonderful drama teacher in college.
但有件事，你知道，我上大学时有一位非常棒的戏剧老师。
Harleen Marley was her name, she was a real mentor to me, but she always said, you know, all plays are about sex and money.
她叫哈琳·马利，她是我的真正导师，但她总是说，你知道的，所有的戏剧都是关于性和金钱的。
That's all any play is about, you know.
任何戏剧讲的都无非是这些，你知道的。
And there was never any kind of virtue or moralizing around it, it was always like, can you just highlight the darker, gross or ugly, you know, the dark underbelly of these characters?
而且周围从来没有什么美德或说教，总是像，你能不能把这些角色的黑暗面、粗俗面或丑陋面，也就是阴暗面给突显出来？
Like, that's what we really want to watch.
就像，这才是我们真正想看的。
And I think we do go to the theater and watch TV.
我觉得我们去剧院看电视也是这样。
Yes, we love virtue, but there's also, you know, we don't trust a story I think that doesn't mix dark and light.
是的，我们崇尚美德，但同时，你知道，我们不会信任一个不把黑暗与光明交织在一起的故事。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲，要在纽约市唱给你听。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
你可能通过 Bravo 电视台的《夏日山庄》认识我，但在我的播客《更多生活》中，我让你们喜爱的真人秀明星们卸下工牌，进行那些你平时听不到的对话。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
那些深度的内容、脆弱的内容、让人感到不适的内容。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我同谢拉·米勒、多琳达·梅德利、汤姆·施瓦茨、林赛·哈伯德以及更多嘉宾进行过深入交谈。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们探讨成长过程中的人际关系、那些剪不断理还乱的麻烦事，以及摄像机关机后发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有《更多生活》的新单集推出，请在各大播客平台收听或在 YouTube 上观看。
I was also just thinking about two characters in television, Archie Bunker and Sam Malone, who are deeply, especially Archie, but deeply dark and Sam Malone and Barney have clear similarities and as a Cheers fan, this must have been on your mind.
我刚才还在想电视里的两个角色，阿奇·邦克和萨姆·马隆，他们内心深处——尤其是阿奇，但他们内心非常黑暗，萨姆·马隆和巴尼有着明显的相似之处，作为《干杯酒吧》的粉丝，你肯定想过这个。
It's my favorite show of all time.
这是我历来最喜欢的节目。
So I would say that we were and Carter's too.
所以我想说，我们和卡特也是。
So we were, we should probably be sued for how similar that characters are in some ways.
所以我们，从某些方面来说，相似度这么高，我们可能都该被告上法庭了。
I see, I really suggest James, and James Burrows, I don't think he's got that much money.
我看，我真的很建议詹姆斯，詹姆斯·伯罗兹，我觉得他没那么多钱。
So he's probably sue me and Carter.
所以他大概会起诉我和卡特。
I think it's probably a good idea.
我觉得这大概是个好主意。
No, but seriously, like, I was thinking too, Michael, like in those articles, sometimes it's an article, you can't get like, just like you said, Josh, they wouldn't be able to get away with Barney today.
不，但说真的，迈克尔，我也在想，就像在那些文章里，有时候这是一篇文章，你没法像你刚才说的，约什，他们今天根本没法让巴尼这个角色过审。
And sometimes they see that same thing about like, Michael Scott about, you know, that character.
有时候他们对迈克尔·斯科特这个角色也有同样的看法。
And it's like, again, I don't think they were advocating for any boss to behave like- Like Scott, I don't think that was Steve Carell's aim or the creators of The Office's aim.
这就好比，再次声明，我不认为他们在主张任何老板表现得像——像斯科特那样，我觉得那不是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的目的，也不是《办公室》创作者的目的。
They're on the side of the looks to the camera.
他们是站在望向镜头的那一方。
They're looking there a little less than a camera, yeah.
他们在那儿朝镜头看一眼，差不多是这样。
That's where they want you to live, your sympathies to live there.
那是他们希望你生活的地方，让你的同理心栖息的地方。
And we are in the reaction shots to the other characters reacting to Barney.
而我们则处于其他角色对巴尼做出反应时的那些反应镜头中。
That's where our current eye are on that side.
我们的爱恨就在那个立场上。
Yeah.
是啊。
But when Barney gets to show that he's really human being underneath it all, I think, and then same thing with Michael Scott, I think there's such value to that.
但当巴尼有机会展现出他内心深处其实是一个真正的人时，我觉得，迈克尔·斯科特也是如此，我认为这非常有价值。
And there's such, it can be very moving, right?
而且那种感觉，真的会很感人，对吧？
when you get a little peak, when you realize there's a human underneath the Darth Vader costume, it's very powerful to realize that.
当你窥见一丝端倪，当你意识到黑武士的服装下面其实是一个活生生的人时，那种觉察是非常有冲击力的。
You know, my mom used to say, if kids can't get good attention, they'll get bad attention, right?
你知道的，我妈妈以前常说，如果小孩子们得不到好的关注，他们就会去博取坏的关注，对吧？
Like there's always, I've heard it said that everything we say is either an expression of love or a cry for love, you know?
就像我听人说过，我们说的每一句话，要么是在表达爱，要么是在呼唤爱，你知道吗？
And it feels like Barney is just crying for love.
而巴尼现在感觉就像是在呼唤爱。
He just comes out in such strange ways, you know?
他只是以那种非常奇怪的方式表现出来，你知道的？
Yeah.
对。
Well, question two is our answer there was longer than Charlotte's term paper for the answer there was longer than the episode of the limo.
好吧，第二个问题是我们的答案比夏洛特的学期论文还要长，那个答案比加长轿车那一集还要长。
It was longer than an actual limo.
它比一辆真正的加长轿车还要长。
Hey, great.
嘿，太棒了。
All right.
好吧。
Well, hard hard hard turn here.
嗯，这里有个急转弯。
We obviously have a lot of people who are very, very interested in the get site mix with living on a prayer, not living on a prayer with help me.
显然有很多人对“Getpsyched”混音带非常非常感兴趣，里面有《Livin' on a Prayer》，不对，不是《Livin' on a Prayer》，是《Help Me》。
What's the Bon Jovi song that gets you love a band, but not a prayer.
邦·乔维的那首歌是什么来着，让你爱上一支乐队，但不是《Prayer》。
Also a great song, but you give love a bad name.
这也是一首好歌，不过是《You Give Love a Bad Name》。
Also, living our prayer starts a little slowly.
而且，《Livin' on a Prayer》开头有点慢。
So you probably didn't didn't that doesn't have that punch at the beginning.
所以你可能，它在一开始没有那种爆发力。
That's why we didn't use that.
这就是我们没有用它的原因。
Yeah.
对。
But a lot of people want to hear about that.
但很多人都想了解这件事。
People are telling me on the internet that somewhere, there's a screenshot of the full mix and the internet has figured out what all the songs are.
网上的朋友们告诉我，某个地方有一张完整混音带的截图，而且互联网已经把所有的歌都找出来了。
Yes.
是的。
One person mentions, I searched the full list of Raphael, Well, Sal don oh seven says I search the full list of Barney's get site mix and one of the tracks was the transformers theme.
有一个人提到，我搜索了拉斐尔的完整清单，Well，Sal don oh seven说我搜索了巴尼“Getpsyched”混音带的完整清单，其中有一首歌是《变形金刚》主题曲。
Yeah.
对。
Love to hear.
很乐意听到。
Wait, I have a question about that.
等等，我对此有个问题。
I have a question about that.
我对此有个问题。
So if there's a shot of that, did you and Carter or any writer write that out or is that Dave Baker, our props guy?
所以如果有那个镜头的特写，是你和卡特或者哪个编剧写的，还是我们的道具师戴夫·贝克（Dave Baker）写的？
We wrote it out.
是我们写的。
Oh gosh, I can't remember.
哦天哪，我记不清了。
We definitely did like a Barney's blog, I think at the time or something where we just put the list out there somehow.
我们当时绝对做过类似巴尼博客的东西，或者在那个时候通过某种方式把这份清单发了出去。
somehow.
通过某种方式。
And is that something you have?
那是你手里有的东西吗？
Like, would you give that to the associate or the assistant writers or, like, what?
比如说，你会把它交给助理或编剧助理吗，还是说怎么样的？
Yeah, I think the writers assistants might have written it up, but we probably pitched the room probably pitched on, like, what are other songs would it be?
对，我想编剧助理可能把它写下来了，但我们可能在编剧室里集思广益过，比如，还会有什么其他歌？
And we probably said the writers assistants and script coordinator, like, can you go write a Barney's blog of this?
然后我们可能会对编剧助理和剧本统筹说，你们能不能写一份关于这个的巴尼博客？
Can you write something where we put this out there somehow, what this is?
你们能不能写点东西，让我们用某种方式把这个公布出去，看看这到底是什么？
And I've seen people recreate it on Spotify, there's, like, lists of it.
我看到人们在Spotify上重新制作了它，上面有类似的歌单。
I think there might have been some discrepancies and errors, because I think the case had a list and people zoomed in on it, and I think some of it was wrong.
我想其中可能有一些出入和错误，因为我觉得道具光盘盒上有一份清单，人们放大了看，我觉得有些部分是错的。
I think maybe had the wrong first song even on it.
我想甚至可能连第一首歌都写错了。
The prop itself was not actually the list, I think that we put out.
道具本身其实并不是我们公布的那份清单，我想是的。
So there's just some discrepancies there.
所以其中确实存在一些出入。
Well, I would like to give a shout out to the How I Met Your Mother sleuths.
好吧，我要向《老爸老妈浪漫史》的侦探迷们致敬。
The Mosby Boys of the How I Met Your Mother verse.
也就是《老爸老妈浪漫史》宇宙中的“莫斯比男孩”（Mosby Boys）。
He always.
他总是。
Which are incredible.
他们真的太厉害了。
Like I remember when Selena Gomez posted a shot of, you could see she was watching How I Met Your Mother.
就像我记得赛琳娜·戈麦斯（Selena Gomez）发过一张照片，你能看出她正在看《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
And it was just the five of us around the table.
画面里只有我们坐在桌子周围的五个人。
And I remember I reposted it.
我记得我转发了。
And I said, what episode is this, you know?
我说，这是哪一集来着，你知道吗？
And it had no, there was nothing overly signifying what episode was.
而且完全没有，没有什么过多的标志能看出是哪一集。
Other than I think what clothes we were wearing.
除了我觉得我们当时穿的衣服。
And all these people wrote me back and they're like, that's so-and-so, like that's this episode.
所有这些人给我写信，他们说，那是某某，就像那是这一集一样。
That's wild.
太疯狂了。
Wow, right?
哇，对吧？
I mean, it's so wild.
我是说，这太疯狂了。
I know I could have said what season it was.
我知道我本可以说明那是哪一季。
I know, I know, but also shout out to Selena Gomez.
我知道，我知道，但也顺便向赛琳娜·戈麦斯（Selena Gomez）致敬。
Big time.
太厉害了。
We would love to have you on the show and talk about how we made your mother, we know you.
我们非常欢迎你来节目做客，聊聊我们是怎么拍《老爸老妈浪漫史》的，我们了解你。
You like it.
你喜欢它。
We are on any time any talk to us.
我们随时恭候，随时来跟我们聊聊。
Yeah.
对。
I'm looking at as many versions of what's on the get psych mix people have posted this, but I can see you give love a bad name.
我正在看大家发布的各种“振奋人心的混音曲”的版本，但我能看到你选了《Give Love a Bad Name》。
I see don't stop believing the transformers theme song, Jesse's girl.
我看到《Don't Stop Believin'》、变形金刚主题曲、《Jesse's Girl》。
Transformer theme song.
变形金刚主题曲。
Come on.
拜托。
That's a good song.
那是一首好歌。
You know what I just saw, Craig?
克雷格，你知道我刚刚看到了什么吗？
Do you know that the SNL sketch where Rick Springfield is is trying to lay down Jesse's girl and it's the drummer.
你知道那个周六夜现场（SNL）的小品吗？里面里克·斯普林菲尔德（Rick Springfield）试图弹奏《Jesse's Girl》，而鼓手……
drummer is Jesse and his girlfriend sitting there.
鼓手就是杰西（Jesse），他的女朋友就坐在那儿。
And the drummer is like, what, what, what are you saying?
然后鼓手说，什、什、你在说什么？
He's like, come on, man, it's just a soul.
他说，拜托，老兄，这只是一首歌。
That's so funny.
太搞笑了。
I've never seen that.
我从没看过那个。
That's a bad idea.
那真是个坏主意。
But Severin, Willie, 99, and so many others would like to know what songs are on your personal get cyclists, maybe one or two you want to throw away.
但是塞弗林（Severin）、威利（Willie）、99号以及其他很多人都想知道，你的私人振奋曲单里都有什么歌，也许有一两首你想扔掉。
What song Sykes you up, no matter what, you know, what's my driving get psych mix?
什么歌无论如何都能让你振作起来，你知道的，我的开车振奋歌单是什么？
If I like really we have a long drive and I know it's gonna be like open road.
如果我真的要进行长途驾驶，而且我知道那会是一条开阔的公路。
You can't play this.
你可不能播这个。
You can't hit play on this when you get in the car and you're in the city and then you're in gridlock because it just feels like ironic and sad.
当你上车时，如果你身处城市，然后又遇上交通堵塞，你可不能按播放键，因为那样会显得既讽刺又悲伤。
But the Joshua Tree by U2.
但是U2乐队的《The Joshua Tree》（约书亚树）。
Oh yes.
哦，是的。
Greatest driving album ever made.
有史以来最伟大的驾驶专辑。
You're right.
你说得对。
That is the get-psych-dist driving album of all time.
那是史上最强的振奋驾驶专辑。
Yes.
是的。
And as I drive, personally for me I lean right into it as I'm heading east on the 10 towards Joshua Tree.
至于我开车，就我个人而言，当我沿着10号公路向东开往约书亚树时，我就会完全沉浸其中。
There's not.
没有。
Do you mean you do that?
你是说你真的这么干？
I remember driving to Joshua Tree one time listening But you have to know you have some highway because I've got I've been the mistake of getting on like I'm in you know This is in your city.
我记得有一次开车去约书亚树，听着……但你得知道，你必须走高速公路，因为我曾犯过这样的错误，比如我开着车，你知道的，这是在你的城里。
All right, we're going away for the weekend Joshua tree where the streets have no name Let's do this and I want to run and you're like no I'm standing still bono Well also the Joshua tree, which is an all-timer for me is is you do not want to shuffle that.
好了，我们要去过个周末，去约书亚树，那里的街道没有名字，让我们开始吧，我想奔跑，而你会觉得，不，波诺（Bono），我还杵在原地呢。而且还有《The Joshua Tree》，对我来说这是一张永恒的经典，你绝不能把它设为随机播放。
It is perfectly ordered too.
它的曲序编排也是完美的。
Oh my God, it's an album that you can't.
哦天哪，这是一张你不能……
Like every song is in the right place.
就像每一首歌都在正确的位置上。
You can't excerpt a song.
你不能把一首歌单独抽出来。
You have to have some whole album.
你必须听完整张专辑。
And then if I listen to all of Joshua Tree, I'm like, I think I'm going on Forgettable Fire.
然后，如果我听完了整张《The Joshua Tree》，我会想，我是不是该去听听《The Unforgettable Fire》（难忘之火）。
Like I'll just roll backwards.
就像我会倒回去听一样。
I stopped, I went, I was so into you too, like in eighth grade, ninth grade, I was so deep.
我停下来，我曾经……我在八年级、九年级时迷U2迷得深陷其中。
And Joshua Tree, I got off the boat, was rattling a home right after that?
到了《The Joshua Tree》，我就下船了，紧接着就是《Rattle and Hum》（神魂颠倒）吗？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, I never got into that record.
对，我从来没迷上过那张唱片。
Like I just, I just left the U2 fold after that, but those early records are some of my favorite things ever.
就像我从那以后就退出了U2的拥趸阵营，但他们早期的唱片是我有生以来最喜欢的东西之一。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
The funny thing is though, I got so obsessed with Joshua Tree that I never fully embraced any other whole daughter album.
不过有趣的是，我太迷恋《The Joshua Tree》了，以至于我从未完全接受过他们的任何其他整张专辑。
Like even though I love Octon Baby, I love some of those early ones.
就像尽管我喜欢《Achtung Baby》，我也喜欢其中一些早期的作品。
Joshua Tree, I would put it up with Abbey Road.
但我会把《The Joshua Tree》和《Abbey Road》相提并论。
It's like one of them.
它就是那种专辑。
That's another great one to drive to, by the way, because it will kill that 50 minutes, however long it is, because you could just roll through it.
顺便说一句，这也是一张非常适合开车时听的专辑，因为它可以消磨掉那50分钟或无论多长时间的车程，因为你可以一路听过去。
So I'm like more of a gets psyched album dude, I think, than a gets psyched song.
所以比起一首振奋人心的歌，我觉得我更像是一个喜欢振奋人心的专辑的人。
Isn't it weird that a band like you two, they couldn't be bigger, and yet they're somehow underrated all at the same time?
像U2这样的乐队不是很奇怪吗？他们已经大红大紫到不能再大红大紫了，却又在某种程度上被低估了？
Yes.
是的。
Like it's a strange phenomenon.
就像这是一个奇怪的现象。
Like they're better than you think they are in weird ways.
在奇怪的方面，他们比你想象的还要优秀。
Like, you know, and I think, yeah, it's hard when things become so popular and they're around for so long, they'd kind of like, you stop appreciating them, there a little bit in the background hum rattles.
就像，你知道的，我觉得，当有些东西变得太受欢迎而且存在了太久，你就会有点不再感激它们，它们就像背景里的嗡嗡声一样渐渐淡去。
I I've got a couple of like like bigger deep cuts like like Fuji's and Lauren Hill like really get get me going and there's a song by Trevor Hall called Indigo that I love so much that I could listen to it whenever it comes on I won't take it off.
我有一些比较冷门但分量很重的歌，比如The Fugees和劳伦·希尔（Lauryn Hill）的歌真的能让我嗨起来，还有特雷弗·霍尔（Trevor Hall）的一首歌叫《Indigo》，我太喜欢了，无论什么时候放出来我都会听，绝对不会切歌。
There's an also an early Genesis song called Follow You Follow Me.
还有一首早期的杰尼斯（Genesis）乐队的歌叫《Follow You Follow Me》。
Do you know that tune?
你知道那个曲子吗？
I don't know that tune.
我不知道那首曲子。
Oh my gosh it's so good.
哦天哪，太棒了。
I do you ever have a song that kind of like, like you'll hear it in a taxi or like it comes to you right when you need it.
你有没有过这样一首歌，就像你在出租车里听到它，或者它在你最需要它的时候恰好出现。
Yeah.
对。
Like, like, it's like, it's a, it's a, it's a, we'll find you when you, yeah.
就像，它会，它会，它会，会在你需要的时候找到你，对。
It's like a hand on the shoulder from God song.
就像是一首上帝把手放在你肩膀上的歌。
Like where you're like, oh, I need it to be reminded.
让你觉得，哦，我需要被提醒。
Like I'm cared for and it's benevolent universe.
就像我被关爱着，这个世界充满善意。
Thank you, Phil Collins and James, you know, that one for me really, really does it.
谢谢你，菲尔·柯林斯（Phil Collins）和詹姆斯，你知道的，那首歌对我来说真的太管用了。
I don't, I'm sure I have so many.
我肯定有数不清这样的歌。
Under pressure, under pressure, David Bowie, Queen, that one will find sometimes the Americans.
《Under Pressure》，大卫·鲍伊（David Bowie）、皇后乐队（Queen），那首歌有时会找到美国人。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
You know, it's another great door to door gets liked album to bring this full circle.
你知道，为了首尾呼应，还有一张适合从头听到尾的振奋专辑。
And I don't think we're ending the episode on this, but born in the USA door.
我不认为我们要以这首歌作为这一集的结尾，但布鲁斯的《Born in the U.S.A.》（生于美国）。
I just listen to an album on a drive door to door.
我刚刚在开车时从头到尾听了一张专辑。
Holy crap.
我的天呐。
That's good.
太棒了。
Do a like Joshua tree.
就像《The Joshua Tree》一样。
There's not a bad one.
没有一首烂歌。
There's just not there's no mess.
真的没有，一点瑕疵都没有。
And it's a perfectly ordered.
而且它的曲序编排完美无缺。
Do you know what else is an incredible springsteen album that is worth a revisit as the rising?
你知道还有哪张斯普林斯汀（Springsteen）的专辑棒极了，值得重温吗？是《The Rising》（崛起）。
Oh, yeah, that's That's a really good album.
哦，对，那是一张非常棒的专辑。
You kind of forget about that one, because I felt later, I remember it was like later Springsteen, but it's still 25 years ago somehow.
你有时会忘了那张，因为我觉得那是斯普林斯汀后期的作品，但不知怎么的，那已经是25年前的事了。
Yeah.
对。
It's like the Simpsons.
就像《辛普森一家》一样。
Like there's no later said like there's only the middle of the Simpsons at this point.
就像没有所谓的后期作品一样，此时此刻只有中期的《辛普森一家》。
Right.
对。
It's all middle.
全是中间部分。
Well, let's just wrap this up here with a little talk about Ted for a second here.
好了，我们简单聊聊泰德，把这部分收个尾吧。
Brian underscore Nars says, was the perfect New Year's Eve concept meant to satirize how much pressure people put on the holiday, or was it more about Ted's optimism and need for control?
听众“Brian下划线Nars”问，完美的除夕夜这个概念是为了讽刺人们对这个节日抱有太大压力，还是更多地体现了泰德的乐观以及对控制欲的需求？
That's a good question.
这是个好问题。
I think the latter, I think Ted's need for control because that's how that's the condition of the start of that episode, and Ted's sort of progress in the episode is to relinquish control and say the party is just right here, and we don't have to stick to the schedule.
我觉得是后者，我觉得是泰德对控制的需求，因为那是那一集开头的情况，而泰德在那一集里的成长过程就是放弃控制，说派对就在这里，我们不必死守时间表。
Also I think it's doing both of those things, I think good art is operating on multiple levels.
而且我觉得这两者兼有，我认为好的艺术作品都在多个层面上运作。
that the questioner just asked all of that's in there.
提问者刚才问的那些内容全都在里面。
So I don't know you can reduce it to like, okay, it was really about this.
所以我不知道你怎么能把它简化为，好吧，这其实就是关于这个。
No, it was about all those things.
不，它关于所有这些事情。
It kind of was all those things.
它其实就是关于所有这些事情。
But I think New Year's Eve is actually a perfect holiday to put Ted under the microscope for.
但我觉得除夕夜确实是一个把泰德放在显微镜下剖析的完美节日。
Because it is a night that is so fraught with expectation and planning and also making future plans or plans.
因为这是一个充满了期望、计划，以及对未来做出规划的夜晚。
plants are plants saying goodbye like Ted is so sentimental about time and and the passage of time and chapters ending and new chapters beginning like he really he really does mark things and he gets very nostalgic but he also has this unshakeable optimism about what's ahead so yeah but but I also think you know some of that he had to be disabused of as this as the show went on I mean So much.
对，就像泰德对时间和时间的流逝、章节的结束和新章节的开始有着极深的感触，他真的非常注重仪式感，而且非常怀旧，但他对未来又有着不可动摇的乐观，所以是的，但我也觉得，随着节目的推进，他的一些想法不得不被打破，我是说，太多了。
I'm shocked at how much of this first season is about Ted's need to plan and control things.
我震惊于第一季竟然有这么多内容是关于泰德对计划和控制事物的需求的。
And Barney trying to shake him out of that, but really the whole show shaking him out of this overly determined life.
以及巴尼试图让他摆脱这种状态，但实际上是整部剧让他摆脱这种过度笃定的人生。
And it's asking him to not surrender control entirely, but at least partner like do a dance more with the universe, which I think he has to learn.
而且它要求他不要完全放弃控制，但至少要像和宇宙跳一支舞一样进行配合，我觉得这是他必须学会的。
People will dance.
人们会跳舞的。
I'm not going to worry about it.
我不会担心的。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请赐予我力量。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被原谅了。
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《How we made your mother》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我——亚历克·莱夫制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our digital content producer, AKA Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg, artwork by John Morrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是点蓝色工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯，我们的数字内容制作人，也就是Z世代大师是艾米莉·布伦贝格，封面艺术由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice, it really does help the show.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目，这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《NYC》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供伴奏音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our Substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表并获取我们的社交媒体链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的 Muse Letters。
Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society also on Substack.
在 CraigThomasRider.com 斜杠 novel 订阅克雷格·托马斯的首部小说，你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解如何做出改变，即本节目为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的持续活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本集的播出得到了 Backyard Ventures 的大力支持。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们确实会跳舞。